Ich bin 73 Jahre alt. Am 14. April 1952. Und wie groß sind Sie zurzeit? 1,78 m. Wie viel wiegen Sie? 86 Kilo.
Herr Bockermann, wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin? Das ist Herr Doktor Müller.
Herr Doktor Müller. Vielen Dank, Herr Bockermann. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ich habe seit gestern ziemlich starke Schmerzen im Bauch. Mehr im oberen Bauch. Und die strahlen auch in den Rücken aus.
Sind diese Beschwerden rechtsseitig oder linksseitig?
Die Schmerzen sind mehr in der Mitte und mehr links.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen in den Ganzrücken?
Nein, auf der Höhe, wo ich die Bauchschmerzen habe, sind die Schmerzen auch hinten im Rücken.
Könnten wir sagen oder beschreiben, wie guttelt für mich?
Ja, kann man sagen, göttelförmig.
Okay. Alles klar. Herr Bockermann, wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10, wo 1 und keine Schmerzen bedeutet und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen?
7 bis 8.
Und können Sie diese Beschwerden schmerzen aushalten oder brauchen Sie ein Schmerzmittel?
Noch kann ich sie aushalten. Wenn es jetzt nicht so lange dauert, kann ich sie aushalten.
Ja, es dauert ungefähr 15, 20 Minuten.
Das kann ich aushalten.
Okay, super.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Bis jetzt nicht.
Was versteckt oder verlinnt hat Ihre Schmerzen, Herr Bockermann?
Also bewegen ist nicht gut.
Ich bleibe lieber liegen auf dem Rücken und ziehe die Beine etwas an, die Knie stelle ich etwas an.
Das ist noch mit am besten.
Okay.
Das ist klar.
Wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben als brennende Schmerz, brennend oder dumpf?
Das sind mehr dumpf und bohrend.
Okay, dumpf und bohrend.
Haben Sie begleitende Symptome wie Übelkeit, Erbruch, Erbrechen?
Ja, mir ist übel ziemlich stark und ich habe bisher auch zweimal erbrochen.
Okay.
Wann war das?
Ja, das eine war vielleicht vor 10 Stunden oder so und das andere war vor 2 Stunden.
Okay, und vor 2 Stunden.
Und wie sah Ihre Erbrochen aus?
Das war ja schleimig-gelblich.
Schleimig-gelblich.
Gibt es keine Blutung oder?
Blut habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay, okay.
Sind Sie diese Beschwerden zum ersten Mal?
Ja, so stark.
Ich hatte vor einem halben Jahr mal auch 2 Tage Bauchschmerzen.
Die waren auch ziemlich stark, aber nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Die gingen nicht ähnlich, ähnlich.
Die gingen nach 2 Tagen aber wieder weg.
Aber jetzt sind sie deutlich stärker und das macht mir Sorgen.
Okay, ich verstehe, dass das für Sie sehr unangenehm ist.
Herr Bekremann, 2 Tage haben Sie, hatten Sie diese Schmerzen damals?
Ja.
Und selbst gegangen sind diese Beschwerden.
Wann war das genau?
Da war ich empfehlt.
Das war vor einem halben Jahr.
Das war im August vielleicht.
Juli, August letzten Jahres.
Okay.
Wegen dieser Beschwerden haben Sie andere Arztbesuche?
Nein, ich war da im Urlaub in Österreich.
Das ging nach 2 Tagen wieder besser.
Dann bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Fieber, Herr Bekremann?
Ja, ich habe Fieber gemessen.
Vorhin hatte ich 38,3.
Ich fühle mich auch so etwas heiß an.
Ich habe auch stark geschwitzt.
Auch seit gestern Abend?
Ja, im Laufe der letzten Nacht.
Wie ernähren Sie sich?
Ich fühle mich ernähre.
Ich esse gerne Fleisch.
Okay.
Meine Frau sagt immer, ich soll mehr Obst und Gemüse essen.
Aber das mag ich nicht.
Ich habe auch viel Fleisch.
Ich esse lieber Fleisch und Kartoffeln.
Trinken Sie viel Alkohol oder Kaffee?
Alkohol trinke ich schon regelmäßig.
2-3 Flaschen Bier pro Tag trinke ich.
Und auch mal 1-2 Schnäpfe.
Ein bis 2 Schnäpfe.
Und Kaffee?
Ja, ich trinke immer.
Ich trinke immer.
Und Kaffee?
Morgen trinke ich 2.000 Kaffee.
2.000? Okay.
Leiten Sie unter Belegungen?
Belegungen?
Oder haben Sie bemerkt,
dass Sie ein Hochkommande von Mageninheit haben?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt bisher.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder enge Gefühle?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Herr Böckermann, ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Sie in der Netzteilzeit in Ihrem Bau
Vorfüllung geschwellen haben?
Oder gelbliche Farbeveränderungen in Ihrer Körper?
Ganz in Ihrer Körper?
Ja, ganz in Ihrer Körper.
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Plankenbereich
oder Umgebung Ihrer Nabel
Farbeveränderungen, wie Bläuliche
oder Brauma?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Herr Böckermann, jetzt werde ich einige Fragen
in der gemeinsamen medizinischen Situation zustande stellen.
Sie haben mir gesagt,
dass Sie seit gestern Abend
Fieber haben
und Froschitz schützen.
Haben Sie auch Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe in der letzten Nacht,
in der letzten Nacht habe ich auch stärker geschwitzt.
Ja, sonst schwitze ich nicht nachts.
Okay.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit oder Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit verändert?
Nein, Gewicht habe ich gehalten.
Appetit, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich esse gerne Fleisch und Kartoffeln.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Ich meine nicht gestern, sondern vorher.
Der ist ganz gut.
Ich habe es schon lange, aber ich kann normalerweise wieder gut einschlafen.
Okay, normalerweise gut.
Außer diese Wasserlastenprobleme
haben Sie andere Probleme in Ihrer Urin?
Zum Beispiel brennende Schmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise habe ich jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Aber jetzt seit gestern habe ich keinen Stuhlgang.
Normalerweise regelmäßig jeden Tag.
Haben Sie Ihre Ernährungsgewohnheiten
verändert in den letzten Wochen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, immer gleich, oder?
Immer gleich.
Okay.
Herr Buchmann, leiten Sie unter Husten
Atemnot, Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Atemnot, Herzstolpern habe ich nicht.
Mein Arzt sagt immer, ich habe eine chronische Bronchitis.
Okay.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich solange schon rauche.
Ich muss morgens häufiger so abhusten.
Wenn ich aufgestanden bin, dann habe ich längere Zeit Husten.
Da kommt auch manchmal Schleim raus.
Das ist im Winter schlimmer als im Sommer.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie chronische Bronchitis?
Ich würde sagen mindestens 5-6 Jahre.
Mindestens 5-6 Jahre.
Wurde bei Ihnen COPD Diagnose festgestellt?
Wissen Sie?
Es war einmal bei einem Lungenfacharzt.
Er hat so etwas gesagt.
Er sagt, er kommt vom Rauchen.
Okay.
Sie leiten unter keine Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Herzstolpern habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nur hohen Blutdruck.
Ich habe schon seit 10-15 Jahren einen Blutdruck.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Stress?
Als Blüher mehr Stress?
Nein, ich habe keinen Stress.
Ich bin in Rente schon seit fast 10 Jahren.
Wenn ich in Rente bin, dann habe ich noch keinen Stress.
Herr Popkermann, trainieren Sie regelmäßig?
Nein, ich trainiere.
Ich gehe zwischendurch mal etwas spazieren.
Aber das ist nicht weit.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Rulogie regelmäßig?
Nein, ich habe keine Rulogie.
Ich habe keine Rulogie.
Wenn Sie Ihre Rulogie regelmäßig?
Nein, ich habe keine Rulogie.
Das war vor zwei Jahren.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Ich gehe alle 1-2-mal im Jahr zum Hausarzt.
Ich brauche auch meine Medikamente.
Ich brauche aber auch meine Medikamente.
Nun, ich habe einige Fragen zu genusten.
Herr Popermann, rauchen Sie?
Rauchen Sie? Ja, ich rauche ungefähr seit 30 Jahren, 35 Jahren rauche ich so ungefähr eine
Stachel pro Tag. Haben Sie schon einmal versucht mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören? Nein. Oder Alkohol?
Nein, das wollen viele, meine Kinder wollen das immer und meine Freunde, die sagen auch,
aufzurauchen, aber ich will das nicht. Ah, okay, Sie wollen das nicht. Ja, wenn Sie wollen und Sie
sollten, Sie müssen eigentlich mit dem Rauchen und Alkohol aufzuhören und ich würde Ihnen gerne
helfen. Ja, aber jetzt habe ich erstmal diese starken Schmerzen und ich finde, die Osten hat ein bisschen geteilt.
Okay, nehmen Sie Drogen? Nein. Nein, aufschnittlich. Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten, Herr
Bokeman? Nein. Nein? Ja, Sie haben ja gesagt, dass Sie an einem chronische Bronchitis leiden,
seit fünf, sechs Jahren und an einem Arterielandhypertonie leiden, seit zehn, fünfzehn Jahren, richtig? Ja,
und ich habe auch noch zwei Gichtanfälle gehabt. Okay. Diese Harnsäure ist erhöht und da muss ich
auch ein Medikament nehmen. Okay, wann war das? Die Gichtanfälle waren so vor drei Jahren und vor
vier Jahren, glaube ich. Vor drei, vor vier Jahren. Gibt es weitere Grundschalkrankungen, Herr Bokeman?
Nein. Nein. Nein. Wo sind Sie schon einmal operiert? Ja, als Kind wurde ich am Leistenbruch
operiert. Da war ich, glaube ich, elf Jahre alt auf der rechten Seite. Mit den Leistenbruch? Ja, rechts.
Und dann hatte ich nochmal eine Operation. Da habe ich meinen linker Unterarm gebrochen. Da war
ich so, wie alt war ich? Da habe ich Sport gemacht, da habe ich Fußball gespielt. Da war ich vielleicht
19, 20 und da war der Unterarm gebrochen, der musste operiert werden. 19, 20, ungefähr Jahre alt.
Gibt es weitere Operationen? Nein. Okay. Waren diese Operationen komplikationslos? Ja, so weit,
ich weiß ja. Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein, Herr Bokeman? Also ich nehme einmal für
die Hansäure, diese Hansäureerhöhung, da nehme ich ein Mittel ein, Moment, das heißt Alo Purinol.
Alo Purinol, wie viel Milligramm und wie oft nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein? Also davon nehme ich eine am Tag und
dahinter steht 300. 300 Milligramm. Okay. Und dann nehme ich noch eine, die eine Tablette habe
ich, die habe ich nicht vertragen, da habe ich stärkeren Husten vorgekriegt für den Blutdruck.
Die wurde gestellt und jetzt nehme ich seit ungefähr zwei Jahren das Mittel heißt Kandesatan. Da
ist der Husten nicht stärker geworden mit der Tablette. Kandesatan, acht steht dahinter,
da nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends. Eine abends, alles klar. Und gibt es weitere
Medikamente? Nein. Zum Beispiel für die chronische Branche. Nein, da nehme ich nichts, da wurde diskutiert,
ob ich da so ein Sprehen nehmen soll und aber ich habe irgendwas gegen Medikamente und da hat der
Hausarzt gesagt, dann wollen wir erstmal gar nichts machen, weil er glaubt, ich bin da nicht so
zuverlässig. Okay. Herr Bockermann, gibt es in ihrer Familie Grundschalkankungen? Ja, mein Vater,
der ist verstorben an Lungenkrebs. Ich such mir sehr leid. Wie alt war er da? 86? 86, ja. Und er hatte
auch hohen Blutdruck. Und die Mutter, die ist verstorben im Alter von 85, sie hatte einen Sturz,
im Haus ist die Treppe runtergestürzt und hatte ein Blutung im Kopf, im Gehirn und sie hatte da auch
einen Oberschenkelbruch und an den Folgen ist sie dann verstorben. Mein herzlicher und Beileiter,
Herr Bockermann. Ich habe noch einen Bruder, er ist 70 Jahre alt, der wurde vor zwei Jahren an
Darmkrebs operiert. Wie ist ihr gesund? Das geht es eigentlich ganz gut. Sie sind Rentner. Was waren
Sie von Beruf? Ich war von Beruf Elektriker. Elektriker. Leben Sie allein, Herr Bockermann? Ja,
inzwischen, ich bin seit ungefähr zehn Jahren, 15 Jahren, ne zwölf Jahren von meiner Frau geschieden.
Zwölf Jahren, okay. Und leben Sie allein? Ja. Seitdem oder? Sind Sie vollständig geimpft? Ja, wenn ich zum
Hausarzt gehe, dann macht er gerade im Herbst immer eine Impfung gegen Grippe und gegen Corona. Das habe
ich jetzt im November bekommen. Aber ansonsten schaut er immer so, was so notwendig ist. Ja. Okay.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Reise gemacht? Ja, aber nicht so wesentlich. Ich war mal in
Österreich und mal an der Ostsee. Aber sonst keine weiteren Reisen, keine Fernreisen. Okay, wann
waren diese Reisungen? Österreich war ich vor einem halben Jahr. Im August, als ich diese Bauchschmerzen
hatte, war ich in Österreich und im Oktober war ich noch mal eine Woche an der Ostsee.
Ja, Herr Bockermann, jetzt möchte ich kurz zusammenfassen. Wenn ich etwas falsch sage,
könnt ihr mich bitte korrigieren. Seit gestern Abend oder Morgen? Seit gestern Morgen. Seit gestern
Morgen haben Sie starke Bauchschmerzen im Oberrennenbauch, aber linksseitig, mittiger und linksseitig.
Mitte und links, ja. Mitte und links, Mitte und links. Okay. Sie beschreiben Ihre Schmerzen auf
einer Schmerzkala mit sieben bis acht von zehn und Ihre Schmerzen strahlen in den Rücken.
In den Rücken, ja. Rücken aus. Bei Bewegung verschlimmen sich die Schmerzen und Sie beschreiben
auch diese, die Schmerzen als dumpf und bohrend. Außerdem haben Sie seit gestern
Übelkeit und haben Sie zweimal erbrochen, einmal vor ungefähr zehn Stunden, einmal vor zwei Stunden
und diese Erbrochene sah schleimig und gerblich aus. Richtig verstanden, oder? Ja. Okay.
Normalerweise gehen Sie zur Zolleze, regelmäßig, für den Stull, aber seit gestern haben Sie
keinen Stull. Ja. Okay. Ja, möchtern Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen an mich? Nein,
Hauptsache mir wird bald geholfen. Ja, ich werde gerne Ihnen helfen, Herr Böckermann. Jetzt werde ich
Sie körperlich untersuchen, Ihre Vizapparameter messen und Blut abnehmen. Danach brauchen wir
einige operativ diagnostische Methoden, um die genaue Diagnose stellen zu können. Wenn wir alle
Ergebnisse zusammengezogen haben, werden wir miteinander noch einmal sprechen. Okay, das können wir so machen.
Legen Sie sich hin bitte, ich komme gleich zu uns her. Alles klar. Gut, danke. Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas
Zeit, das umzuschreiben, die Patientensprache in Fachbegriffe. Okay. Die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen, die heute Abend hier dabei sind, haben vielleicht noch Fragen. Ich habe eine Frage. Ja.
Herr Böckermann, gibt es irgendwelche Ausstöße für dieses Schmessen? Zum Beispiel haben Sie
vielleicht vorgestern viel Alkohol getrunken oder nach dem Fatiga Ess speisen? Ja, vorgestern
habe ich, da war ich beim Nachbarn, der hatte Geburtstag, da habe ich vielleicht ein,
zwei Schnäppze mehr getrunken. Das kann sein. Danke schön. Okay. Der Schmerz ist immer da.
Manchmal wird er etwas schlimmer. Manchmal kommt so eine Welle, aber das ist nicht sehr oft,
aber ich habe immer, immer, der Schmerz ist immer da, nie weg. Würde bei Ihnen Magandam-Spiegelung
irgendwann durchgeführt? Nein. Danke schön. Die Schmerz, dann hatte ich ja vor einem halben
Jahr mal, da waren sie aber nicht so stark und das dauerte nur zwei Tage und das war im Urlaub
in Österreich und danach bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen, aber eine Magenspiegelung wurde noch
nie gemacht. Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt. Hallo. Ich habe heute einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen,
habe sehr kurz Zeit dafür. Ja. Es handelt sich um Paul Bochermann, einer 73-Jährigen Patientin. Er stellte
sich heute wegen, seit gestern Morgen bestehender Abdominalgie bei uns vor. Er beschrieb die Schmerzen
auf einer Schmerzkala mit sieben bis acht von zehn und als durf- und bohrend. Bis jetzt hat er keine
oder seine, sein Hausarzt oder andere Arzt nicht besucht, zum ersten Mal zu uns gekommen ist und
zuerst ist er zu uns gekommen. Er schmerzt ihre Schmerzen, seine Schmerzen schmerzt ihn in den Rücken,
wie gut er für mich die Abdominalgie stehen, besonders in der Mitte und mehr links-seitig. Im
gesamten Bauch oder mehr im Unter- oder Oberbauch? Oberbauch, er hat gesagt, ja. Okay, ich fasse
einmal kurz zusammen. Der 73-Jährige-Patient, Herr Bochermann, berichtet über starke Abdominalschmerzen,
überwiegend im Epigastrium links, mit Ausstrahlung nach Dorsal. Genau. Mit Ausstrahlung nach Dorsal.
Ich bitte nicht in den Rücken sagen, möglichst nach Dorsal. Dorsal, okay. Ja. Und der Schmerz
wird als dumpf und bohrend beschrieben auf der Schmerzskala zwischen sieben und acht. Ja? Genau.
Okay, gut. Ja? Okay, er hat dagegen keine Medikamente eingenommen. Wenn er, nein, bei Bewegung
hat er diese Schmerzen schlechter gefühlt und wenn er seine Knie beugen, zum Mitte beugen,
hat er sich besser, oder diese Beschwerden besser, ist diese Schmerzen besser geworden.
Ja, Sie können auch sagen, diese Schmerzen verschlimmern sich bei Bewegung. Genau. Ja?
Ja, verschlimmern sich bei Bewegung und bessern sich bei Rückenlage mit angewinkelten Kniehen.
Also angestellt in Rückenlage, wo ich sage. Okay, angewinkelte. Hat der Patient diese Schmerzen
schon mal gehabt? Vor einem halben Jahr, als er nach Österreich gegangen ist, hat er zwei Tage
solche Beschwerden, aber nicht so stark und diese Beschwerden sind selbst gegangen,
deswegen hat er keinen Besuch, keinen Arzt besucht. Okay, gut. Fragen nach, Entschuldigung,
zuerst möchte ich sagen, dass er außer dem Nausea und Emesis hat und seit gestern hat er
zweimal erbrochen, einmal war es vor zehn Stunden und einmal war es vor zwei Stunden und sein Erbrochene,
seine Erbrochene sah schleimig und geltlich aus. Okay, gut. Außer dem hat sie seit gestern Abend
Fabrikes gefühlt und er hat einmal gemessen, es war, er war, der Körperzentrum war, 38,3 Grad,
außer dem hat er Schütterfrost, nein, Schritzen, Schütterfrost und ja nächtliche Hyperhydrose.
Okay. Ich habe gefragt, dass, wie er sich ernährt und er ernährt sich normalerweise viel Fleisch und
Kartoffeln, außerdem trinkt er viel Bier und Schnepse, zwei bis drei Flasche biatäglich und
auch Schnepse zwei bis drei, zweimal, ein, ein bis zweimal, Entschuldigung. Wir können dazu sagen,
sagen Sie ruhig dazu, es besteht ein erheblicher, ja, ein erheblicher Alkoholkonsum, erheblicher,
erheblicher, heißt ja, also schon er deutlich erhöht, okay, Alkoholkonsum von zwei bis drei
Flaschen Bier pro Tag und zwei bis drei Schnepsen pro Tag. Das ist schon, das ist schon ein erhebliches
Maß zu viel Alkohol. Okay, okay, ich verstehe, ich bin abgeschön. Vorgestern ist er eine Einladung
gegangen und er hat viel getrunken als vorher, ja, eins bis zwei Schnepsen. Schnepse, ja. Mehr, mehr Schnepsen,
genau. Wozu Frage noch zu den allgemeinen Zeichen hat der Patient Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen und
beim Stuhlgang? Ja, Wasserlassen, hat er normalerweise täglich zweimal Wasserlassen, besonders in der Nacht.
Kennen Sie da den Fachbegriff für nächtliches Wasserlassen? Genau, Necturie,
und normalerweise sein Stuhlgewohnheit ist sehr regelmäßig, aber seit gestern
hat er keinen Stuhl mehr. Patient hat normalerweise täglich Stuhlgang, täglich, täglich Stuhlgang,
aber seit gestern nicht mehr. Nicht mehr, seit gestern nicht mehr, okay. Ihr Appetit oder Gewicht
hat sich in der Zeit nicht verändert. Tragen nach Retro-Starnheit, Horax-Schmerzen,
Engelgefühl, Icterus, Reflex und Flutulenz wurden verneint. Tachycardi auch wurden verneint, aber er leidet
an einem chronische Bronchitis seit fünf bis sechs Monaten, deswegen hat er es im Winter
schlimmer geworden. Man kann sagen, er hat morgens einen produktiven Husten.
Produktiven Husten, ja, also mit Expektoranz. Genau, genau. Und er rauf regelmäßig einschaffte
pro Tag seit 35 Jahren und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint. Sagen Sie dann ruhig, sagen Sie dann ruhig, es
besteht ein Nikotin ab Usus von 35 Packageiers. Packageiers, ja. Eine Packung pro Tag, 35 Jahre,
kann man sagen, 35. Genau, das ist einfach. Packageiers. Bei ihm ist keine Allergie,
unsere Verträglichkeiten bekannt, sind es, schuldigung, nicht, ist. Er leidet an, er leidet
außer dem, an einer arteriellen Hypertonies seit zehn bis 15 Jahren, außer dem hatte er zweimal
Arctitis urica. Ja, sehr gut, ja. Vor drei Jahren und vor vier Jahren. Dagegen nimmt er regelmäßig
täglich 300 Milligramm Alu Poinol und er leidet an ein, ja, Artelibaton habe ich schon gesagt.
Und deswegen hat, nimmt er seit zwei Jahren regelmäßig Kandesartern acht Milligramm
morgens und abends ein. Bei ihm wurde mit elf Jahren, oder ja, eine Operation durchgeführt
in Guinalhaini. Ja, in Guinalhaini Operation im rechten Zeit durchgeführt und wegen einer
Fraktur, welche Fraktur, unser Arm Fraktur, Radius oder Urla, in Linken Arm eine Operation
durchgeführt im Jahr von 19 oder 20. Ja, im Alter, im Alter von 19. Im Alter von, im Alter von genau.
Okay, das waren die Operationen, ja, gut. Genau, ja. Und gibt es Erkrankungen in der Familie?
Ja, seine beide Eltern sind verstorben. Seine Vater hat einen Lungen Bruchiat-Karzinom erlitten und
mit 68 Jahren ist er verstorben. Seine Mutter war 85 Jahre alt und er hatte einen Unfall.
Zu Hause ist sie gestürzt oder gestürzt. Ja, gestürzt. Eine Treppe hin und wieder gestürzt.
Und Gehirnblutung hatte sie damals? Der Patient hat gesagt, sie hatte eine Gehirnblutung. Sie können
ruhig sagen Schädelhirntrauma. Wir wissen nicht genau. Sagen Sie ruhig, die Mutter erlitt ein
Schädelhirntrauma und was noch, was noch für eine Verletzung? Und noch ob das eine Fraktur hat.
Daran ist die Mutter verstorben. Genau. An diesem Urfallfolgen ist die Mutter verstorben.
Okay, gibt es Geschwister? Ja, er hat ein Bruder, er ist 70 Jahre alt, vor zwei
Jahre hat er einen Kolonkwarzinom erlitten und er wurde operiert und er ist jetzt gut.
Ja, es geht ihm ganz gut. Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Die Beschwerden sprechen für eine Pankreatitis. Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen eine akute
Holististitis und Gastroenteritis in Betracht. Um eine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen werde ich
den Patienten zunächst körperlich untersuchen. Natürlich zunächst die Zeitparameter messen,
Blut abnehmen, EKG schreiben, um mögliche Herzerkrankungen auszuschließen. Danach werde ich
ihn körperlich untersuchen. Im Blut weide ich amylase, oder Cross-Hes-Blut-Bilds,
Tromponentheka, TKMB, amylase, lipas, biliribin, alp, AST, GGT, Verze, kommentiert.
Gut, vielen Dank. Das beherrschen Sie perfekt. Vielen Dank. Das können Sie. Die Verdachtdiagnose
kann ich teilen. Eventuell ist es ja so, dass es schon der zweite Schub einer Pankreatitis ist.
Vor einem halben Jahr hatte der Patient auch ähnliche epigastrische und Dorsale-Schmerzen
nicht ganz so stark. Man kann eventuell davon ausgehen, dass er da schon mal einen Pankreatitis-
Schub hatte. Und jetzt ist es schlimmer, heftiger, stärker. Es spricht einiges dafür. Der Patient
hat einen erheblichen Alkoholkonsum. Vor zwei Tagen hatte er wahrscheinlich noch mehr Schnaps getrunken
bei der Beier. Das spricht alles ein bisschen dafür. Und die Differenzialdiagosen kann ich
gut nachvollziehen. Man muss eventuell reflektorisch denken, dass er vielleicht einen Subilius hat.
Kein Stuhlgang seit gestern. Das ist aber oft reflektorisch der Ilius ja aufgrund der Schmerzen,
der Abdominalschmerzen. Aber auch das muss sicherlich gut abgeklärt werden,
nicht, dass der Patient auch noch einen Ilius entwickelt zu der Pankreatitis. Gut,
aber ich denke, Sie haben das ja gut gemacht, worauf Sie achten müssen. Ich habe Sie sehr gut
verstanden. Worauf Sie achten müssen, ist, dass Sie die Zeit einhalten. Sie haben vielleicht den
Gong gehört nach 20 Minuten. Da kam eine Musik, da ist oben so eingestellt. Sie waren am Ende bei
24 Minuten für die Anamnese. Und ich glaube, Sie haben in der Prüfung 20 Minuten Zeit.
So wird mir das zumindest berichtet. Da achten Sie bitte ein bisschen drauf, dass Sie in dem
Zeitrahmen bleiben. Sonst kann es passieren, dass vielleicht dann gesagt wird, so jetzt ist 20
Minuten, jetzt können Sie nicht weiter fragen. Jetzt ist die Anamnese zu Ende, dass Sie da versuchen,
die Zeit gut einzuhalten, das Zeitmanagement zu optimieren. Also ich habe Sie sprachlich
sehr gut verstanden. Sie haben auch, denke ich, gute Fragen gestellt und Sie können auch die Fachbegriffe
gut. In der Prüfung haben Sie etwas mehr Zeit, sich die Begriffe wie nächtliches Wasser lassen,
dass Sie das gleich markieren und dann übersetzen. Nüktorie. Die Leistenhernie können Sie eventuell
noch sagen, im Alter von elf Jahren erfolgte eine Herneotomie. Herneotomie, genau. Wegen Leistenhernie
rechts oder Ingrinale hernie rechts. Das wäre dann perfekt. Aber es ist nicht zwingend notwendig. Aber Sie
haben das gut, guten Fachsprache haben Sie gut eingesetzt. Gut. Ja, also ich sehe Ihre Prüfung
übermorgen, würde ich jetzt sagen, können Sie so gelassen entgegen sehen, wie es geht. Es ist
immer Stress, aber Sie sind, glaube ich, gut vorbereitet.